actuellement bien de tendance du
consommateur avant la can est indéniable
et il ya actuellement un plus grand
nombre de canettes sur le marché que de
bouteille au canada trois bières sur
quatre sont consommés hank haney
en cinq ans la part de marché de la
bière dans un contenant de l'aluminium
est passé de 39 à 64% et cela
principalement chez les grands brasseurs
du comportement du consommateur qui au
fil du temps s'est adapté pour des
questions de facilité de manutention des
transports alors si je suis un
consommateur de bière et je vais faire
un geste pour l'environnement est-ce que
je l'achète en canette je lâchais pas en
bouteille m'a bien en fait vous
l'achetez en bouteille la plupart des
bouteilles en verre sont des contenants
à remplissage multiple
alors que les canettes d'aluminium sont
à remplissage unique d'un affichage
multiple d'omar le contenant les plus
écologiques et le consommateur ou
intimement le choix le centre
international de référence sur le cycle
de vie des produits le ciraig analysé en
2015 le coût environnemental réel des
deux types de contenants confirmant
l'avantagent de la bouteille de verre
par rapport à la canettes d'aluminium
le fait de réutiliser la bouteille de
bière en verre une quinzaine de fois
fait comme un amortissement de son
impact environnemental
l'enquète du ciraig démontre par contre
que la canette aurait un impact
similaire à la bouteille de verre si
elles étaient produites ici
or ce n'est pas le cas les deux
principaux fournisseurs de canettes
d'aluminium sont établis aux états unis
dans l'état de new york et en
pennsylvanie qu'avant une canette qu'on
reste ici c'est très bien ne serait
jamais contre pas avoir une bouteille
qu'on réutilise est encore mieux
pour l'association des microbrasseries
du québec
l'engouement pour la canettes
d'aluminium soulève des questions là la
pression en ce moment est très très
grande à prendre le virage vers la
canette pour pour les microbrasseries
c'est des décisions d'affaires qui ont
des impacts concrets
très significatif pour les
microbrasseries adresse que je me des
parties de ma ligne d'embouteillage au
profit du nom à canet 2
c'est plusieurs centaines de milliers de
dollars parfois le est ce que un jour on
va aller ça pour ça un canal dans notre
industrie gens d'autres fort c'est
beaucoup plus facile à
opérationnellement par la dette rangs
caennais quatre ans en bouteille la
bouteille amène un système de gestion
des contenants consignés il faut être
dans un système de réutilisation du
contenu les microbrasseries ont souvent
leurs propres formats de bouteilles
certaines d'entre elles ont des
fonctions bien précises certaines
bouteilles qui ont des caractéristiques
comme cela ici là qui ont une espèce de
de fond qui est un peu en beauce et le
champenois
ça permet de la refermentation malgré un
système de consigne privé ces formats
uniques cause parfois des maux de tête
aux détaillants avec raison parce qu'il
est fort motion différente donc
d'entreposage et compliqué presque
personne ne revient les chercher
a contrario du butin de bière standard
donc s'écrire une espèce de d'anarchie
si on veut au niveau des contenants de
bière et contenant qu'on a eu on a plus
qu'une seule fois ravard occupe 7 % du
marché 7 % du marché
c'est beaucoup de contenants on parle de
centaines de plusieurs centaines de
milliers de contenants effectivement sur
le soulor ont un enjeu de récupération
[Musique]
l'avenir idéal pour vous ce serait quoi
si les brasseurs continue à vouloir
mettre sur le marché plus tôt des
canettes en aluminium que des bouteilles
en verre à serait de développer une
filière locale de production d'aluminé
mais le contenant réutilisable anvers a
vraiment une performance
environnementale intéressante donc ça
serait dommage de l'abandonner sur tout
pillé déjà quand même pas mal dans les
moeurs de tout le monde la consigne on
connait puis on sait que ça fonctionne
la collecte sélective et la consigne
sont deux systèmes complémentaires
fonctionner tous les deux le message que
je voudrais que le genre cern ne m'étais
pas un contenu on se mit à la poubelle
[Musique]